no prey is too small here in the
Gorongosa National Park in Mozambique 21
year old Ricardo Goethe is out hunting
but he's not looking for lions or
elephants he's looking to bag insects
with the scolding say push this insect
belongs to the beetle family in the
ground beetle family if you touch it it
secretes an acidic liquid the Cardo
works with pure tone ah Scratchy
a Harvard professor he's here in the
park to document the diversity of its
insects musics yeah in Gorongosa
international scientists work with young
locals to find out about Mozambique's
rich biological heritage in recent weeks
Ricardo has caught thousands of insects
for the parks team of experts to
identify the Gorongosa our database is
still a work in progress it contains
information on all the animals and
plants found in the park and that
includes insects they play a key role in
the food chain
Ricardo Goethe is studying agriculture
but his professors enthusiasm is
contagious and now we'd like to study
calling after ology in the u.s. first of
all they're always very colorful after
nightfall is when insects come into
their own professor no scratchy is set
up a light trap based on the principle
that moonlight influences insect
behavior
believing the artificial light is the
moon the insects begin to spiral so they
remain parallel to the light source it
is insects who actually around the world
they are some of the most important
elements of almost any ecosystem almost
any terrestrial ecosystem they provide a
number of services without which we
wouldn't be able to function so things
like pollination you know all these
moths without them all the trees and
plants without around us wouldn't be
able to produce fruit the people who
live near the park have other concerns
but the next day we get to see how
they're starting to benefit from the
protected area locals used to live
mainly from poaching now they have
regular jobs a wealthy American donated
40 million dollars to the National Park
in hopes to boost tourism schools and
hospitals are under construction and a
new research laboratory has also been
completed as we drive deeper into the
park we come across elephant dung
elephants are returning to the region
the civil war in Mozambique in the 1980s
wiped out the local animal populations
slowly but surely
they're coming back
even while the Gorongosa Park was shut
down and abandoned the insects never
left ruins make an ideal habitat for
them but now they're facing another
threat
Ricardo Goethe takes us to his village
on the way we pass logging trucks most
of the timber is destined for China
Ricardo hates to see the widespread
destruction of his country's forests but
he knows how expensive electricity is
which is why locals depend on wood fuel
I think we're running the risk of losing
our biodiversity too much forest is
chopped down for wood fuel generally
speaking people don't have enough
respect for nature
back at headquarters
the insect hunters are working
tirelessly today they're setting up nets
the researchers want to find out more
about the feeding patterns of bats they
make the most progress at night Jen
chitin and expert on bats is using an
instrument to identify sounds that human
ears can't normally hear the recordings
are highly informative Gorongosa is a
perfect place to study this because we
have a high diversity of bat species a
high diversity of insect species and
we're surrounded by areas that suffer
from malaria and also where people grow
crops so it's an ideal place to study
the interaction between bats and insect
species that plague humans soon should
release the bat back into the wild
but first it will have its picture taken
the scientists are counting indigenous
species in the park
we're told that scientists are only
aware of about 10% of existing insect
types in coming years the researchers in
Gorongosa Park will likely discover
thousands more thanks in part to Ricardo
and isn't it
you